انجاز طبي تويجا بفرحه عائلات طفله
اماراتيه مريضه تعد الاصغر في الشرق
الاوسط تخضع لعمليه زراعه قلب فبخطوات
دقيقه ومحسوبه انتقل الى الامارات فريق
طبي من مستشفى الملك فيصل التخصصي ومركز
الابحاث الرياض يقوم بعمليه ازاله قلب من
متوفي في دبي والعوده الى الرياض لزراعاته
في جسم الطفله وذلك في اقل من 24 ساعه
كانت الطفله اعتمدت لاشهر على مضخه
اصطناعيه لعدم توفر المتمرين
[موسيقى]
ثقه كان لدينا الطفله من الامارات العربيه
المتحده وكانت تعاني من فشلا في القلب فتم
قبولها في مستشفى الملك فيصل التخصصي
بالرياض وتم نقلها بالاخلاء الطبي لكي
تحظى بالمتابعه الطبيه ومحاوله تقديم
العلاج اللازم لها لما تعاني منهم المشكله
في القلب ااه
كمرحله الانتقاليه تم وضعها في البدايه
على مضخه القلب الصناعي لمده تقارب
للشهرين حتى يتوفر المتبرع للقلب من اماره
دبي فتم انتقال همم الفريق الطبي متكامل
عن طريق الاخلاق الطبي الى الامارات وتم
الاتصال العضو من المتبرع به وتم نقله
مباشره مره اخرى الى الرياض وتم زراعته في
الطفله همم بعد ذلك كانت العلميه ولله
الحمد مرته همم في همم من نجاح الى نجاح
واستقرت حاله الطفل بشكل كبير جدا وبعد
موضي شهر ونص تقريبا من اجراء العمليه تم
خروجها الى البيت بصحه جيده معدويها ومع
اهلها وهي الان في المنزل ولله الحمد من
قرابه اسبوعين ووضعها
جدا مستقر وتحت متابع اسبوعيه من الفريق
الطبي المعالج طيب دكتور الملفت انه
العمليه تمت في وقت قياسي في اقل من 24
ساعه انتقل الفريق الطبي الى دمي الى دبي
حمل القلب الى الشمس في الرياض تم زراعته
هناك ما هي ابرز التحديات التي واجهتكم
دكتور في هذه الزراعه طبعا هناك تحديات
كبيره فاولا من ناحيه العضو المزروع تم
نقله من دوله اخرى فهذا يعني لابد الوجود
التنظيمات لوجستيه كبيره همم فتم التنسيق
همم في البدايه بين مركز زراعه الاعضاء في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ومركز زراعه
الاعضاء في الامارات العربيه المتحده همم
حينما تم ايجاد الحمد لله العضو من ال- من
المتبرع به فتم انتقال الفريق الطبي عن
طريق طائرات الاخلاء الطبي التابعه لوزاره
الدفاع السعوديه انتقلت الى اماره دبي او
تم معاينه همم القلب من المتبرع به وتم
الاتفاق على انهم مناسب للنقل فثم تم
اسراء والعوده به مباشره بحيث ان الساعات
ساعات ساعات قليله جدا التي لابد ان يتم
فيها زراعه القلب
فهذه التحديات من عمليه التنسيق الدولي
ومع طائرات الاخلاق طبي تحضير الكوادر
الطبيه المؤهله الاعداد الغرف العمليات
همم لكي يتم زراعه العضو بشكل سريع لابد
من تجهيزها وعمليه التنسيق الكبيره فهذه
تعتبر تحديات كبيره لا تتمنا ولا توفر
البنيه التحتيه والكوادر الطبيه المؤهله
والخدمات
اللوجستيه من الطيران والتعاون الدولي بين
السعوديه المره الشقيقتين
[موسيقى]